hunters are going in and killing large
family groups the young orphans are left
because they're too small to be sold as
meat so I had only been here a month and
then I was given the opportunity to look
after an infant gorilla the reason my
whole life turned upside down and I
stayed was because of Karn Daniel
affection Africa exists in collaboration
with the Cameroonian government who can
go and confiscate these orphans and then
we bring them out into metho we're home
to most of the primates that you find in
Cameroon
when an orphan comes in to the center
there's the whole process of 3-month
quarantine the correct health procedure
to get them emotionally and physically
strong enough in all different factors
coming to that as to which family group
that we choose them to be introduced
into
[Music]
the de carne Daniel was handed to me
we've got news that he'd been rescued in
a village I'd never even seen a gorilla
that small and I'll put him on me and he
grabbed on for dear life and for such a
little thing he had a grip on him so the
arms were round the little feet gripped
hard and that's where he stayed for two
years it wasn't him having to learn how
to be with me it was me having to learn
how to be a gorilla so that he could
understand I obviously did gorilla
vocalization with a slight British
accent I tried my best button on gorilla
when he got to a certain age they learn
a lot through socializing with each
other and play you know there's only so
much he's gonna get from me
[Music]
is that funny I mean he's the love of my
life if somebody said to me would you
have given all that up for him to be
back where he should be then I'd have
happily not ever met Khan Daniel the
same as I'd have never met any of these
because they're not meant to be here
with us they're meant to be in the
forest all the ones that are in I care
now
they're all safe they're not a risk
anymore is that something to be proud of
not really we're a sticking-plaster over
the problem
the future of these individuals it all
lies in the human hands really they
can't change anything they're not doing
anything that ensures their survival
[Music]
if chimpanzees and gorillas disappear
from wild forest areas then we've done
that as humankind it's black and white
it's like okay we're either going to
solve this or we're going to destroy it
[Music]
[Music]